can you explain to people why an Ice Age
isn't like the movie I think the common
perception for humans is when it's an
ice age everything in the world is
completely frozen over nothing can live
except a little squirrel with Acorn well
we're in the [__] Ice Age we're still
in it like we're in an interglacial
period in an ice age right now 53
degrees in New York while we're filming
this yeah yeah
well yeah it's not snowball earth like
it's not this planet snowball idea you
know you know millions and millions of
years ago there may have been periods
like that but no I I Ice Age and the
with a glacial maximum refers to like
when we had the laurentai the cordaran
and the European glaciers you know these
two miles of ice that were sitting up on
top of the northern hemisphere of the
planet